NARRATOR: Thomas and
Jennifer are investigating
one of Tutankhamun's secrets.
Excavating under a ruined
fortress for evidence
he got his gold from the
inhospitable Eastern desert.
Did his miners shelter here?
The team has just
found something.
Stone blocks that
offer a tantalizing
glimpse of a settlement
from Tutankhamun's time.
So these are
architectural blocks.
They carry some hieroglyphic
inscription very faintly
visible here, which would
indicate that they were carved
and set up in some sort
of building which dates
to the reign of Tutankhamun.
It's exciting,
because that gives us
a sort of a ballpark
for the time when
this site was busy and
active and important
during the 18th dynasty.
NARRATOR: Jennifer's team must
now move the precious blocks
offsite for further analysis.
As they dig deeper into the
layers below the fortress,
they uncover more clues
that this site was
in use in Tutankhamun's time.
JENNIFER GATES-FOSTER:
It is beautiful.
This is a really distinctive,
very different from any
of the Ptolemaic material,
the Greek style pottery
that we find in most of
the rooms of the Fort
that is really common.
This kind of pottery, which
belongs to the New Kingdom,
is not wheel made.
It's handmade, and
you can tell that
by looking at the
interior of the pot, which
has a surface which
is very irregular
and that it's been smoothed
with a smooth stone most likely.
NARRATOR: It's not
just one or two pieces
of Tutankhamun-era pottery.
Jennifer's team is
revealing that the layers
of Earth beneath the fortress
are packed full of it.
JENNIFER GATES-FOSTER:
We have New
Kingdom material
under the floors of
rooms 20, 19, 26, 18, and 17.
But to have the Fort now
documented on top of deposits
that indicates some kind of
occupation in the New Kingdom
and that's really exciting.
NARRATOR: The discovery
is proof the site
may have been used
in Tutankhamun's time
by his gold workers.
But the team have found
another remarkable clue
concealed in the fortress.
Cutting into the bedrock 60 feet
below the surface is a well.
It's a vital source
of water that
explains why the safe haven
and Tutankhamun's gold workers
were here.
THOMAS FAUCHER: The well was
built the time of Tutankhamun
by the evidence we have now.
It was, I guess, more precious
than even than gold for people
that they can have water
to go inside the desert.
NARRATOR: The evidence
here and at other sites
reveals how Tutankhamun
got his gold
from the remote Eastern desert.
Miners had to trek
vast distances
from the Nile Valley
across the hot, dry desert
to reach the gold mines.
Ancient engineers dug
wells along the route
for precious drinking water.
Each well was a day's
walk from the last,
creating a network
of vital rest stops.
This allowed them to
survive the brutal journey
across the desert to
mine gold in the East
and bring it back
to their Pharaoh.
Thomas and Jennifer
have revealed
one of Tutankhamun's secrets.
Sites like this were a critical
part of the infrastructure that
allowed him to amass the
gold for one of the most
elaborate burials in history.
JENNIFER GATES-FOSTER:
The gold in Tut's masks,
all that gold in
his tomb, that's
coming from the Eastern desert.
So sites like this that
looked really modest
are actually the
mechanism that allowed
New Kingdom gold to be mined.